der mars vibriert und das viel häufiger
als bislang gedacht und das erschüttert
all unsere bisherigen vorstellungen zum
aufbau des roten planeten kommen wir mit
den neuen spektakulären erkenntnissen
der nasa-sonde insight dem innenleben
des mars endlich auf die schliche klicks
um science fiction die spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocken nur dann verpasst ja nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen übrigens
klicks um science-fiction gibt es jetzt
auch als podcast täglich auf die ohren
der link dazu ist unten in der video
beschreibung schon im april des
vergangenen jahres 2009 10 hatte das
seismometer der nasa mars sonde inside
eine faszinierende aufnahme gemacht bei
dem zittern wie die forschungsteams es
bezeichnet haben handelt es sich
tatsächlich um ein erdbeben auf dem
roten planeten eine premiere denn
niemals zuvor konnte seismische
aktivität auf dem maß gemessen werden
laut nasa eine historische messung und
somit ein spektakulärer erfolg der
seismograph seismik experiment forint
terrier structure kurz sei es wurde von
der französischen weltraumbehörde cms
entwickelt und befindet sich schon seit
dezember 2018 auf dem mars das
instrument horcht quasi in den roten
planeten hinein um erschütterung zu
registrieren und ist dabei von den
extremen winden und
temperaturschwankungen auf dem roten
planeten geschützt mit hilfe von seis
sind die fachleute also in der lage ins
innere des roten planeten reinzuhören
quasi sowie ärztinnen und ärzte mit
ihrem stethoskop in den menschlichen
körper horchen können tagsüber gestaltet
sich das als schwierig denn dann lässt
der stürmische maß wind den staub tanzen
und die feinen erschütterungen
verursachen ein rauschen im detektor
anders ist das in den abendstunden dazu
der insight experte bruce banner wir
haben bisher hintergrundgeräusche
gesammelt doch dieses ereignis markiert
offiziell den beginn eines neuen
forschungsfeldes der erdbeben kunde des
mars mittlerweile gibt es zahlreiche
detaillierte erkenntnisse die
verschiedene forschungsteams in ihrem
fachartikel präsentieren auch der
endgültige beweis wurde erbracht dass
der mars tatsächlich aktiv ist die
messung der vergangenen monate haben
zudem auch gezeigt dass es auf dem roten
planeten deutlich häufiger vibriert als
man bislang gedacht hatte seit mitte
februar 2009 10
feuchter erdbeben sensor ins innere bis
ende februar 2020 wurden seitdem
insgesamt 450 maß beben registriert fest
steht jedenfalls dass diese maßgaben
unsere vorstellungen über den roten
planeten auf den kopf stellen dazu der
schweizer seismologe domenico giardini
vor der landung von inside haben wir
rund 2500 modelle zum innenleben des
mars gesammelt zur struktur zu den
physikalischen eigenschaften und zur
dichte des planeten wissen sie wie viele
dieser 2500 modelle heute noch gültig
sind kein einziges die detektierten
beben stellen die experten und
expertinnen also für ein großes rätsel
wo liegen die ursprünge und wie können
die beben entstehen schließlich besteht
der mars doch nur aus einer einzigen
platte die beben könnten also anders als
die meisten erdbeben auf der erde nicht
durch die verschiebung von
kontinentalplatten zustande gekommen
seid so dachten die fachleute zumindest
bis jetzt die auswertung der bisherigen
daten liegt zwei verschiedene typen von
mars beben nahe
zum einen konnten eher schwache beben
registriert werden die sich durch
hochfrequente signale auszeichnen die
fachleute gehen davon aus dass die
ursprung in geringer tiefe in der mars
koste zu finden ist die beben sind in
der küste gefangen und verbreiten sich
quasi ungedämpft die signale können
hinweise auf dem wassergehalt der küste
geben und das wiederum sind
entscheidende informationen für
zukünftige mars missionen als
vergleichsmöglichkeiten bieten sich die
erde und der mond an die mondkruste
enthält kein wasser hier werden die
wellen gestört und der detektor empfängt
sie aus verschiedenen richtungen
komplett gegensätzlich auf der erde wo
das untergrundgestein ein sehr hohen
wassergehalt aufweist die bisherige
analysen zeigen dass der mars irgendwo
dazwischen liegt doch die den wellen
ähneln eher denen auf der erde denn noch
ist der genaue wassergehalt der mars
kruste noch nicht erforscht doch das
konnte ein weiterer typ der mars beben
identifiziert werden hierbei handelt es
sich um bislang registrierte 24
ereignisse die über eine geringe
schwingungsfrequenz verfügen und wohl
aus dem tiefer liegenden mantel stammen
in der fachsprache ist von der
lithosphäre die rede die magneten dieser
beben liegen zwischen 3 und 4 und
breiten sich in unterschiedlichen tiefen
des mars mandls aus die beben verraten
den forschungsteams viele neue
informationen
über das innenleben des mars dazu der
us-forscher blick auf basis der
wellenbewegungen können wir rückschlüsse
auf die geologischen schichten innerhalb
des planeten ziehen das forschungsteam
ist sich mittlerweile sicher dass die
maß kostet sehr stark zerklüftet ist und
das bis in einige kilometer tiefe und
das ist eine absolut sensationelle
erkenntnis der obere mantel scheint im
vergleich zu den unteren mantel
schichten stärker zu dämpfen das zeigt
die ausbreitung der wellen die
auswertung der bisherigen beben legt
außerdem nahe dass in der mars koste
kleinere mengen an fluid enthalten sind
also einer flüssigkeit die fachleute
vermuten dass es sich möglicherweise um
salzige lösungen handelt die forscher
hoffen nun zeitnah ein starkes beben
detektieren zu können denn die dann
ausgelösten wellen könnten sogar bis zum
mars kern vordringen und so auch seine
zusammensetzung offenbaren bislang gab
es zwei beben mit durchaus
aussagekräftigen signalen das epizentrum
konnte in der region zerborsten
gentrifizierung werden hier gibt es
auffällige fast parallele brüche in der
mars oberfläche die höchstwahrscheinlich
in der jüngeren vergangenheit entstanden
sind dem vulkanischen einfluss sei dank
aufgrund dieser beobachtung gehen die
fachleute davon aus dass doch auch
tektonische spannungen für die
seismische aktivität des verantwortlich
sind dazu domenico giardini die
stärkeren erdbeben die wir lokalisieren
konnten stammen von einem tektonischen
grabensystem in der region
cerberus vor bislang ging man dagegen
davon aus dass die beben vor allem auf
die abkühlung des planeten
zurückzuführen sind doch jetzt ist klar
im gegensatz zu den vorherigen annahmen
dass sich auch auf dem mars tektonische
spannungen in form von beben entladen
also ähnlich wie auf der erde
eine absolut super spannende und
sensationelle erkenntnis und die konnte
auch bezüglich des magnetfeld ist das
maß gemacht werden so offenbarte sich
das lokale magnetfeld in der ebene
elysium plant nizza als zehnmal stärker
als bisher angenommen offenbar gibt es
in der näheren umgebung magnetisierten
gesteinen in der maß kostet übrigens
gelang es uns auch mit genau dieser
technik also uns menschen den aufbau des
mondes zu verstehen durch der analyse
einiger tausend leben auf dem mond im
zeitraum zwischen uns
69 1972 konnten forschende nämlich die
einzelnen schichten des mondes
nachvollziehen und so wird die raumsonde
insight dem mars noch mindestens ein
weiteres jahr beobachten
und da sind wir dann wirklich auf die
sehr spannenden erkenntnisse gespannt
und die fachleute sind sich sicher dass
da noch einiges kommt dazu schreibt ein
us forschungsteam diese beobachtungen
werden zu neuen entdeckungen im hinblick
auf das innere des mars und seiner
geologischen entstehungsgeschichte
führen finden wir 2021 endlich leben auf
dem mars anklicken anschauen und neugier
zu abonnieren sehr sehr cooler kanal mit
sehr sehr coolen videos also unbedingt
draufklicken unbedingt abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran